toxic air is choking colombia's capital
bogota
a thick cloud of smoke looms over its
eight million people
carried by dry winds hundreds of
kilometers away from fires burning in
the amazon
secretary
we have decided together with our
secretary of health to decree a yellow
alert for the prevention and care of
severe respiratory disease in bogota
throughout the public and private
hospital
system the air quality is so bad the
government says it's best to stay mostly
indoors
but for those who can't it's come at a
cost
the yellow alert for pollution haunts me
because i work on the street every day
and it's harming my lungs more than it
should because it has increased more
in colombia's amazon record temperatures
and deforestation blamed on former farc
rebels are creating a combustive mix
here the defence minister gets a
first-hand look at the nation's largest
national park a unesco world heritage
site under threat
national park was burnt by criminal
hands that seek through this practice to
deforest to appropriate the land and the
responsibility for this abhorrent
practice lies with the farc dissidents
since the farc rebels disarmed and gave
up control of the territories they once
held destruction of the amazon has been
on the rise
groups of rebels who rejected the 2016
peace deal with the government are
accused of starting fires to graze
cattle or grow coca to make cocaine
its effects are now being felt in cities
across colombia priyanka gupta al
jazeera